Voiceover:Which numbers
are greater than six?
Select all that apply.
We see six here on the number line,
so the numbers that are greater than six
are going to be the ones
that are to the right of six
on the number line.
We see that we're increasing beyond six
as we go to the right.
Six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
Seven is greater than six,
eight is greater than six,
nine is greater than six,
and 10 is greater than six,
and we could keep going.
11 is greater than six,
and 12, and on and on and on.
Which of these are greater than six?
Well we see 10 is to the right,
is on the right hand side of six,
eight is also to the right of six
but four is to the left of six.
Four is less than six.
These are the two numbers
that are greater than,
the two choices that are greater than six.
Which numbers are less than six?
Well that's all of these
numbers right over here.
The numbers to the left of six.
Nine is definitely not less than six
but four is.
Notice four is to the left of six
and three is even more to the left of six,
so four and three are
definitely less than six.
When every day life
when you're thinking of
well if you have four things,
or you have three things
you have less than someone
who has six things.
In every day life if you have 10 bananas,
you have a greater number of bananas
than someone who has six bananas.